ripeti quello che hai detto e rivoglio
voglio che tutti sentano vai ho detto
che ti spacco in uno contro uno su quake
live se dopo vero che ti spacchi anche
se la signora abbiamo sentito abbastanza
oggi famiglia era incontro al cup parte
ma tu hai partecipato a tornei di quake
live si saranno quarto al mondo tre
volte campione europeo
una volta avrà la famiglia
io una volta ho aperto una scatola di
coach frates e l'ho mangiata tutta in un
solo giorno al mio ruolo sarà quello di
tentare di ucciderlo almeno una volta
avrò così allora diciamo così proprio
bene la mia molti campioni del mondo di
quake perché sennò faccio un po più
pixel
tanto nessuno sa che sei arrivato quarto
facciamo finta riservato primo ayachi e
male in faccia fortissima come fatto a
vedermi
oggi vi faccio vedere come si batte un
campionato dei campioni del mondo
aspetta aspetta in sta preparando misure
ma aspetta e sta calcolando tutto sto
capendo come spari e poi giochi e ora
come sono morto band e poi giochiamo
seriamente allora sarà un music è
arrivati i parenti impegnati 100 glory
[Musica]
che male in faccia come fate uscire da
lì va bene ai ha convinto anche l'altro
ci questo forte stato uno sono io
dove sono
da una parte ciò che valuto mai le devi
mettere come altri miei quelli a prato
il 50 vita abbiamo 300 ma tu mi senti
quando si guarda mediche la ragazza era
morta
26 fatti sopra ai ackermann e dal colpo
ma per che cosa è successo nel mondo
[Musica]
sorpresone ma si sapeva
questo fa male
attenzione
[Musica]
un no che vale aiuto
minchia ho visto la morte in faccia
fortissimo
porca eva maledizione conto vi di vita
rimasta al 91 non aveva molta che caga
aerei avanti ma così è successo a solo
con l'arma corpuscolare attenzione ha
visto di questo accordo ma lo faccio a
caldo davide sai ancora io non ho tanto
140 ora dovete ancora tre colpi 1 ma
perché sono scarso devos ignorarlo dai
fatti no non sei morto
tutti i maschi sotto ogni o niente
tutti contro 60 era già io sto facendo
solo così l'unico modo per vincere
dobbiamo farla in duello con quel che le
armi le devi raccogliere assisi si certo
certo
attenzione
ora zero come cosa qua il mondo perché
esiste taglia che il dolore né idee né a
chi dolore
[Musica]
perché se da del dell'arma non male ma
tu sei uno che io vado dove non voglio
vederti e tu ci sei
dopo il gira a sinistra ci sei tu e lo
ricorda la destra che non c'è ci sia a
destra come fai
se ne possibile ne è impossibile non
c'ero più thomas in una sola partita
sandro desse il via dal probabile allora
che vorrà giocare con un proprio sono un
campione di quei chiedo ragiona come se
io ho vinto il torneo mondiale di quel
che io l'ho vinto dove al è arrivato
quarto e dove deve entrare nell'ottica
dell'incisore che io sono il vincente io
sono io sono fortissimo
io sono forti sono il vincente quello
che vince sono sono quello che vi io
faccio il culo a tutti non per me non ce
n'è per nessuno
by tom oggi forse non riesce uccidere
una volta una flora guarda che sono il
vincente io da eva niente niente
riuscirà mai a l'arma sono uscito
come sei stato bravo arezzo ne pensate
porca vacca
sacher e mi sento uccidervi a sentire ha
passato di qua ma dove saranno qua 7 più
elevato ben 10 adesso non può rendere
noti o scambiato per una cassa verde
molto colpito una volta in crisi sono
morto da solo ti spacco del 28 a meno 3
tua 80 strada non muore mai
non muore mai quell'uomo ma sei qua
sotto
tutti però quello che faccio e tutte
twittato tutte le volte sei morto una
volta mise recuperato corano è che
schifo
29 almeno tre se uno entra in partita
adesso ha più punti di me quanto direi
di fare l'ultima che ne dici sì sto dopo
una killer a devo fare solo una kill non
è difficile si è difficile però luglio
abbiamo ossia non poche protezione siamo
sempre campo aperto dai partiti che vado
da dio ma com'è possibile che sono così
morton sono anche partiti male
no perché da oggi colpito ma edizione
c'è max the magic
tutto questo è sì ben note vaime 65
così si gioca questo e problemi questi
problemi ma edizione così si gioca
a genova da solo contro la benedizione
di stanotte dormo tranquillo ma non ci
fosse per cadere mentre ti spingi vero
che un tissi mari quello che c'e dietro
con un mitra di euro all'indietro
hai sentito le munizioni tensione deve
prendere l'oro
[Musica]
sono caduti all'inguine ma come era lì
tutto è concentrato le aspettavo che
uscissi dietro la morte onda di lievito
va beh diciamo che la mappa l'abbiamo
scelta po cattiva ragazza però mi ha
ucciso con di nuovo ora di un niente di
fatto cadere
allora devo riprendermi niente una fraia
però è una rottura di balle che vuole
può essere considerata una vittoria
ti ho tolto una killer su 44 khalifa e
munizioni succede anche questo ragazzino
distratto io uccido piuttosto via disco
47 a meno tre in realtà mi ha
disconnesso nel summer quindi la
vittoria ipoteticamente della pure dal
sistema bellissima jeans
grazie il gioco riconosce la supremazia
para maledizione guarda imparato ma
sempre e sempre ti devo insegnare le
cose così devi allenarti di più guarda
chi l'aveva di stare guarda guarda i
giocatori che ci mettono impegno nei
videogiochi questo è quello che fai un
play ballare assessore ho capito che sia
piaciuto al costo si riduce notizia mi
lascia anche il cane di thomson
descrizione e noi ci vediamo a mano
possiamo da ragazzi
[Musica]